you had a conversation with Glenn Lowry
and John McWhorter and
from there it became clear to me
I think John made clear how important to
uh the conversation about race is
policing into in today's society that
that's where a lot of African-Americans
feel is sort of the the Pinnacle of
racism sits the people that believe
there's still racism in America there's
still a lot of racism in America that's
where it is so um
to what degree do you think there's
widespread institutional racism and
policing yeah well
uh my first book
yeah was a book called race crime in the
law
and uh 1997 1997. wow
that's time flies time flies
um
unfortunately
yeah the
the impetus behind that book
stands
that book was
propelled
by a sense that with respect to the
administration of Criminal Justice
uh African-Americans
are
uh feel deeply aggrieved
and they feel deeply aggrieved with good
reason
reason in at least two dimensions
on the one hand
uh African-Americans suffer
from under protection and in fact in
that book the central theme of that book
was that black Americans suffer from
under protection if you take a look at
the broad
you know the sort of the broad
trajectory of American history
and ask yourself
what you know in what way have black
Americans been
most
oppressed
well
take a look at
the Antebellum Period
period before the abolition of slavery
before the abolition of slavery
in the the locales where most black
people resided namely the slave states
in a lot of those areas question was
there a crime called the murder of a
black person
answer for a long period the answer was
no
there might have been a tort you know so
of a white person killed the slave a
killed a Slave
uh that person could be sued
because they had they had injured the
property
of another
and would have to pay money to you know
for that but had they committed a crime
answer no
um
in the Antebellum Period
were black women protected
against the crime of rape
in Most states the answer was no there
was no such crime
let's go to after
you know slavery is abolished
thank God slavery is abolished then
let's see you know what happens what you
know so we hear lynching lynching
between the from from 1890
until let's say 1930.
well me you know in 1890 there were
there was probably you know I would say
but it was probably on average a
lynching every day in the United States
you know well over 300 lynchings
uh it goes down that was the case in the
1890s probably the first decade of the
20th century and then it starts going
down
what was lynching about
lynching was about black people being
executed
outside the law
did the legal system do anything about
that answer no
you know you you show me show me cases
in which people were prosecuted
criminally
for engaging in lynching
you come up in most places with a null
set
black people suffered the under
protection of the law do black people
still suffer the under protection of the
law the answer is yes and people talk
about the Kerner Commission report 1968
uh black people were asked you know with
respect to the police
what's your what's your main complaint
in many places the main complaint was we
don't have police protection
you know when when things happen to us
when our houses are burgled
when our businesses
are um encroached upon by robbers when
our businesses are robbed
when we're assaulted
you know nothing happens
the police protect white people they
don't protect us
under protection
our society right now if you take a look
at the statistics
who is most liable to be raped robbed
the victim of assault
uh what have you
black people
I mean and then it's and it's not even
close
under protection
so that's one way in which the
administration of Criminal Justice
harms black people by not
doing what government is supposed to do
which is protect us
14th Amendment you know
protect equal protection I underline
protection of the law
so that was a big theme of race crime in
the law now second thing second and this
is the thing that gets most attention
and it's important I think that the
under protection story does not get
enough attention but then there's a
second story The Second Story is that
black people
have historically and still today
uh black people are subjects of
invidious racial discrimination when it
comes to
when it comes to
um police action
so you know uh
walking down the street
you have
a black person who's let's say 20 years
old you have a white person who's 20
years old let's make them men both just
walking down the street
and question
attitude of the police towards these two
an attitude you know is a complicated
thing it can show itself in various ways
it can show itself in a look
it can show itself in who who gets the
look
you know
black persons you know walking down the
street or running down the street
white person's walking down the street
or running down the street
uh what happens with respect to the
police
um
let's suppose that you know who who gets
the second look
who is followed
who is detained for a moment
well some of it uh just a on a small
tangent I apologize to interrupt but
attitude is an interesting one
um
because a lot of it a lot of the
interaction doesn't show up in the data
so detained for example starts showing
up in the data but before then the
second look the third look the first
look this is where the gray area of
conversation happens because uh
very much so culture and Society happens
in the stuff that doesn't often show up
in the data yep
yep so I tell you uh this really came
home to me
several years ago I was I was in New
York City
and it was at a time when
there was a lot of discussion over the
um stop them first stop and frisk
basically you know racial profiling on
the street I was walking I was I was I
was in Harlem
I'm walking down the street
and
frankly you know the police weren't
bothering me I'm just walking no the
police weren't bothering me but you know
I'm of a certain age
I I did notice though I was I was
looking at the police
and
the way that the police
attitude it had to do with body posture
it had to do with that's right who got a
second look it had to I noticed I'm
walking in the street I'm walking in
Harlem
they're you know they're they're white
people on the street you know most of
the people that were black
some some Hispanic
the level of contempt
the level of animus
the level of unfriendliness
that was pouring off the cop the police
they weren't they didn't say anything no
they didn't detain they didn't say
anything
it was palpable I could feel the
attitude that was being
directed at the young black men and the
thing is see the thing is
it's not as if this doesn't matter it
matters because the way I saw it these
young black men knew they felt
the contempt that the police were
shedding and this was going to have a
consequence the consequence it was going
to have is let's imagine that the police
did say excuse me
um
uh you know what are you up to
now if you have been feeling this
contempt
if you feel like the officer who was
asking this question doesn't like you
doesn't know anything about you but just
doesn't like you on site
you might answer in a certain sort of
way
you're not going to give the cop the
benefit of the doubt and basically think
well you know policeman's just you know
asking me this you know probably just
trying to make the neighborhood safe
well if if that's your feeling you know
the police was just asking me this
trying to make the neighborhood safe
well officer the reason why I'm here is
such and such
and you know thanks for your service
that's one response
another response is
I'm not going to tell you anything
you know I'm not going to tell you
anything I know that you don't meme any
I don't I know that you don't mean me
any good
I'm not going to tell you anything am I
free to leave
and then the cop having heard that
then says something bad you know after
five minutes what do you have you have
an altercation on your hand
and I I felt that and that is part and
you're absolutely right that's not
written down it doesn't get to court
it's it's it's it's it's there
but it's it's an important part of
street life
it's an informal part of Street and it
has Ripple effects because that young
black man will probably talk [__] about
that cop later that day so the narrative
persists and then the cop will also talk
[__] and that there's these narratives
and I think the contempt is such a it's
such a powerful thing it's so hard to
disentangle because you're absolutely
right the young man
let's suppose that the story ends quote
well right
he's gonna go
and he's gonna be talking with his
friends and he's gonna say Let me let me
tell you what just happened to me
and his friends are going to say oh yeah
that doesn't surprise me let me tell you
what happened to me
and you know for two hours this goes on
the anger the feeling of humiliation the
feeling of a grievement
grows
it's disseminated
and that's part of what we have but
that's not all of that's not that's
that's that's you know that's a
important part of what we have but we
have it's even worse than that because
then you ask the question
you know what about what about
things we do know
um I know this from you know from my
teaching
this was brought up
you know there was a lawsuit in New York
City
and notice I didn't say you know I
didn't I didn't say Birmingham Alabama I
didn't say Atlanta Georgia I didn't say
Tallahassee Florida I didn't say you
know the Deep South I didn't say Montana
I didn't say Idaho New York City
yeah
Cosmopolitan Place Metropolis
in New York City the police were
challenged with respect to their
policies
a judge wrote a very lengthy opinion
and the facts were rolled out and the
facts were really quite horrifying
people they were there were there were
there were black men who had been
stopped many many times it wasn't just
once
over and over and over again
under circumstances in which they ought
not have been stopped
and you know this has real consequences
it doesn't just show up here though of
course it also shows up in other places
with respect to the administration of
justice
and uh we still have uh you know a big
problem now you mentioned you know the
police
if you ask yourself
who are the state agents
that are most
consequential
the police
I mean you walking down the street what
other agents
have guns on them
what other agents are authorized by the
law
to shoot you under certain circumstances
it's the police the police are the most
consequential agents of the state that
most people interact with I mean there's
there's a um to push back a little bit
of consequential in it in in the
physical sense but if we return to the
power of the psychological sense of
contempt I would say store clerks and
stuff like that can also be a source
they're not agents of the state right uh
but if we look at the landscape of
contempt which throughout the 20th
century
you know or the bus right uh that you
could experience the same kind of
contempt UK in other aspects of society
but yes the cops can I with consequences
still put the police the policemen
or the police person
is the person walking down the street
with a gun gun yeah
and if you think about the way in which
the law
the the extent to which the police are
authorized
to use their Force the police have
extraordinary
uh you know extraordinary Authority you
know you look you're you're driving your
car
and you're speeding
the police can arrest you right then and
there
and take you to jail
that's an extraordinary power but they
also have because of that the leverage
just one human to another they have more
leverage to be an [__] and to show
contempt to you to be to be the Lesser
to lean into the Lesser aspects of their
Natures all humans can just to be an
[__] to show contempt you had a bad
day
they have the more freedom to do that
yes and that's why that's why
uh police officers are very important I
recognize I mean I I you know I know
police officers they have a very
difficult job
uh a very important job very important
again remember what I talked about under
protection I want the police to protect
me I want the police to protect me from
the rapist the robber so I you know the
police
I'm with the police we need good
policing
we but
we need good policing and for good
policing we need accountability and one
of the scandals one of the just absolute
scandals of American law is the extent
to which the police are not held
accountable
it's absolutely remarkable the the
degree to which American law
fails to properly hold police
accountable
they have an important job a difficult
job I want them to be very well paid
as far as I'm concerned you know we
should be if police should make more
money
uh they should be given given the
importance of what they do they should
have more respect more Prestige more
money with all of that they should be
held accountable
and the way things are now they're not
held accountable and every day we see
the consequences in our newspapers or
just you know talking with people so
what do you make of the different
perspective on this uh from to to bring
up a person that I'll probably speak
with Heather McDonald
who wrote uh
a book called war on Cops and uh will
often bring up
the stuff that does show up in the data
to show the disproportionate amount of
homicides committed by African Americans
and uh we'll also justify racial
profiling on that basis in stop and
frisk programs and we'll also bring up
things like uh the Ferguson effect uh
saying that because of this pushbacks
pushback and all the stuff we've been
saying about
police
in those areas the police will step back
and crime will increase I was in one
debate with her and one of the things
that I said is it was a debate that was
that was sponsored by the Federalist
Society conservative Legal Group
you know these were law conservative law
students at Harvard Law School we had a
she made a presentation and they asked
me to respond and one of the things that
I said was
when we're talking about the police
I'm
um
I'm disappointed
with the
uh
reaction
of some of my conservative colleagues
and I would consider her to be one of my
conservative colleagues because what are
the sort of the what are some of the
the important
precepts
of conservatives
one very important precept of
conservatives limited government
limited government
you know would a conservatives talk
about the tendency
of government to overreach itself and
governmental agents
to overreach themselves
and I say you're right
you're right I I you know right on
why is it that you somehow forget that
when you're talking about the police
you're never you you seem to be
unaware of this tendency that is so much
in your Consciousness and other places
but now when you're talking about the
police
you make it seem as though I'm you know
other people are being paranoid
when they talk about the danger of
overreach we need to be very careful
about the danger of overreach another
thing with respect to the pollution what
to conservatives
transparency in government
you're right you're absolutely right we
need transparency in government so why
is it that so often when we're talking
about policing
why is it that conservatives actually
embrace police unions
and are the enemies of transparency
why is it that you want to prevent the
citizenry from knowing that officers so
and so
has you know there have been 10
incidents in the last year in which
citizens have complained about office or
so and so don't you think that the
citizenry ought to know that why is it
that you want to keep that Under Wraps
so overreach transparency the tendency
or you know the problem of governmental
agent corruption
um why is it that those sorts of things
are forgotten about
when some conservatives by the way not
all conservatives not all conservatives
there's some conservatives
who has stuck
and appropriately sowed their guns
and have said a
uh we need to make sure that the police
stay in their Lane we need to make sure
that the police do not overstep
constitutional bounds we need to be we
need to insist on transparency there are
some conservatives who have taken that
line and I salute them but there are a
lot of conservatives and I would say
Heather McDonald is one of them who all
of a sudden
become just you know totally uncritical
status when they're talking about the
police so the the overstepping overreach
the lack of transparency
um of course we see this kind of stuff
in uh foreign policy as well which is uh
starting military conflicts and a lot of
the supporters at least the uh with the
Iraq and Afghanistan wars were
conservatives and and Hawks and so on so
there's a lot of hypocrisy in terms of
principles and so on
um but maybe one question is
in this discussion about racism and
policing there was a lot of
um cops that might listen to this
and feel like they're not being
the profession is not being respected uh
they're not being heard
not being respected to the difficulty of
the problem they're facing and uh can I
just interact remember a few moments ago
I mean if if if I were in charge of
things if I were in charge of things I'd
pay police
more in fact much more
than they receive
um I do police have a very difficult job
extraordinarily difficult job I mean for
one thing you know sort of maintaining
the law the law that's a very
complicated thing the law
that's not an easy thing I mean I teach
law
I spend a lot of hours with very smart
people trying to understand the law very
difficult
so here we expect people to understand
the law at the same time that they are
grappling with people some of whom are
violent
it's very difficult I respect police
officers and I said we need police
officers you did not hear me say by the
way so for so let's let's get down to
Branch tax
you did not hear me say defund the
police did you in fact to the contrary I
said defund
actually I want more funds
for the police I want to hold them
accountable I understand the difficulty
of their job
I respect the police I want people to
respect the police I also want the
police to respect
civilians and demand that they do
uh I am not a police abolitionist far
from it far from it again we need good
policing
for good policing we need good people
to a degree
it's almost philosophically maybe
practically do you think police should
be doing racial profiling
profiling in general okay it's a very
difficult
philosophical moral
human question yeah so first thing we
need to do
and here we get back to the you know
early part of our conversation because
we focus so much on you know first part
of a word
here we have another word profiling
question what is racial profiling
now here we have you know in the weeds
uh we have people talking past one
another
I've been in conversations with police
officers and debates and
uh we talk past one another because we
are defining racial profiling very
differently if you ask I've been on I've
been in conversations with police
officers and they say oh I'm totally
against racial profiling and then I say
well you know sir what do you mean by
racial profiling and here's what they
say
racial profiling is when police officers
act against somebody wholly on the basis
of race
that is that gets rid of the issue
because
you know most police officers don't act
against anyone wholly on the basis of
race
you could have the most racist police
officer and that that police officer is
not going to act adversely against the
90 year old black woman walking down the
street with a cane okay so it's always
it's so there you know if you Define
racial profiling that way you're getting
rid of the issue
the issue is the proper issue is this
should the police
be able to act against someone
uh taking race into account as a factor
so let's imagine that a black person
who's 25 years old is walking down the
street right next to a white person
who's 25 years old
some people would say you know what
under those circumstances it's okay for
the police officer to give two looks at
the black person and only one look at
the white person why because the
statistics tell us that the black 25
year old there's much more risk of that
person acting in an unlawful way if you
take a look at you know crime statistics
and ask the question
um
uh with respect to you know homicide
with respect to robbery with respect to
various you know crimes
uh what's the what what is there a is
there is there a difference between the
white 25 year old and the black 25 year
old with respect to certain crimes the
answer is in certain places the answer
is yeah there's a difference
and there's a and there is a greater
risk that the black 25 year old has
engaged in various forms of criminality
I'm not you know that okay
under those circumstances what do I say
should the police officer therefore
be allowed to take action vis-a-vis the
black person as Oppo you know as against
the white person my answer is no
I'm fully willing to concede let's
concede for the point of art you know
for the point of discussion that there
is more risk
there might be
but
for
reasons of constructing the sort of
society I want
we should not Empower agents of the
state
to act towards certain people
uh in a way that's you know adverse to
them
let me try to break this down in a
little different way
um
let's go back to
let's let's let's let's talk about what
happens when you want to get on an
airplane
you know it wasn't so low you know 9 11
wasn't all that long ago it was a while
ago but it wasn't all that long ago and
this very issue came up with the respect
to the profiling
of Muslims and there were some people
who said geez you know in the aftermath
of 9 11
profiling of Muslims makes sense
you know no hard feelings but you know
the 11 people who you know were on those
planes were all Muslims
now
there is a rationale you could just
simply say it's not it's not Prejudice
it's not animus it's not invidious it's
just
you know the facts take us this way well
the facts never take us this way there
are facts and then there is our choice
of how we want to respond to those facts
now you could respond by saying well
we perceive Muslims to be more likely
to you know do bad things on an airliner
you could you could respond in that way
on the other hand you could say no we
want a society
in which people or do not have to
Grapple
with prejudice on the basis of their
religion on the basis of their race
and to deal with that we are going to
demand we're going to demand that agents
of the state
act towards people in the same way
and so if that means
that
everybody getting on the airplane before
they get on the airplane
has to
you know open up their luggage
and it slows things down
foreign but everybody has to open up
their luggage
I would prefer that
over a system in which we focus on
people who are Muslim and one of the
reasons and I'm gonna bring this back to
our to the racial thing one of the
reasons why I I want to insist upon that
is because if you know if we all have to
open up our luggage
what that means is we're all paying a
tax
for more security
and we're all likely to ask ourselves
hmm do we want to pay this tax whereas
if we focus simply on the Muslims and
allow the Muslims to be the only ones
who are sort of paying the tax
we'll force that on them
same in the you know black person white
person 25 years old walking down the
street
do we want to impose a racial tax on the
black 25 year old
some people would say yes I say that's a
mistake black people aren't stupid they
know that they're paying this tax
it is a violation of it seems to me the
rules that we ought to want to have to
govern our society
I say spread the costs
make the police deal with everybody
the same
um and don't don't allow a situation to
develop in which a group of people can
can
um accurately say
we are paying more of a cost than these
other people over here so it's a better
avoiding profile is uh
while it may have
uh costs on security in the short term
in the long term it's the embodiment of
the principles that all men are created
equal so it has a much bigger benefit
yes in representing the fairness yes
that is uh at the core of the ideals of
this country yes